sure I mean you know you never actually
saw her die you just saw her go down in
a giant ball of flames yes look good
Forks pretty dead
that looks pretty dead it's a way back
there's always way back but I'm sure
there's always a way forward who knows I
just want to see you wear that hat again
that was badass
yeah I never say no to anything think of
the costume you get to be pimpin you
splice together between those two maybe
Helen could out Helens hella Helen the
the baddie Helen is not a great it's not
a great name for a baddie Helen Helen
hello but hello could maybe I'd maybe
turn you nice so this interview is
blowing up right now people are
wondering what does this mean so let's
break this down and talk about some
possibilities if you're new to my
channel I'm giving away one more copy of
Avengers infinity war and then I'm doing
a very special giveaway after that so
all you have to do to enter is subscribe
to my channel like this video and
comment below with your thoughts and
your favorite superhero
so in this interview you hear cate
blanchett talk about there's always a
way back and there's always a way
forward and that she is definitely open
to coming back as hella so obviously the
first question everyone asks and wants
to know is that will hella be in
Avengers 4 oh maybe and the answer is
probably no but not definitely no I
thought you'd be happy to see
a lot of people confuse hella the
goddess of death with death herself they
are not the same people
however Marvel can kind of do whatever
they want in the MCU whoever I am did
you listen to a word I said so they can
kind of make them the same person if
they wanted to and have fan O's fall in
love with hella in the mid credit scene
of the first Avengers movie we see the
other talking to Thanos and he says to
challenge the Avengers is to court death
Thanos then turns around with a big grin
on his face this is obviously an ode to
Lady Death however she has not been
mentioned at all since that line and the
storyline of Thanos trying to collect
all the Infinity stones to rebalance the
universe is way different than Thanos
trying to collect all of the Infinity
stones to wipe out half of the universe
because his woman mistress death is said
that there are more people alive than
there are dead so two very different
motives here and I do not think they're
going to cross the two together in the
Avengers 4 movie but since Disney now
owns the x-men again there is a
potential for us to get another infinity
stone movie that takes after the
Infinity Gauntlet saga from the comics
this storyline is where he's trying to
do everything for death and there are a
lot of Marvel characters in this
Wolverine Cyclops a bunch of different
people that Marvel now owns and can use
in movies it's such a big story with
mistress death that I don't think
they're just going to throw it into the
second half of Avengers infinity war
however there is another option where
they could bring her back as hella
herself and not mistress death again
they are two different people
I am hella
his firstborn commander the legions of
Asgard the rightful heir to the throne
and the goddess of death as she
mentioned in the interview she would
love to see hello come back and partner
up with Thor which has happened before
in the comics and we do know that time
travel will be a big part of Avengers 4
however this is still very unlikely
there's only a few ways that they could
do this they could one wait for Odin to
die go back in time right when that
happened and tried to convince her to
help them right when she gets out of the
prison that Odin trapped her in not very
likely considering how hostile she was
and thor ragnarok so he's cold
[Music]
Touche know we've liked have seen that
or the other option is to convince Odin
to let her out and fight Thanos with
them but this doesn't make much sense
either because you would just ask Odin
himself I would love to see Odin fight
Thanos and the last way is something
that is in a supposed plot league for
Evan just for it is that Thor will
actually go to hell and ask her to help
supposedly she's enticed to help because
she wants to be the strongest person in
the universe and Thanos would obviously
be the strongest person at that time so
she agrees to help Thor I don't see this
happening it just seems a little too
messy there's already so much going on
in the movie and again if there's time
travel involved just go back and get
Odin so I don't see her coming back in
Avengers 4 but there's so much room and
opportunity for her to come back in the
Thor sequels and I do think they would
save a story like that for another movie
I don't think they'll attract a
convolute Avengers 4 with so many
different stories going on at the same
time and in the interview she's
basically saying yeah I'm open to coming
back not I have come back and I have
shot scenes for vendors for and I will
be returning she's open to the
possibility of it happening sometime so
my opinion we're not going to see her in
Avengers 4 but let me know what you all
think do you think there's a good way to
slide her into the story plot of
Avengers 4 let me know your thoughts in
the comments below
again the infinity war blu-ray giveaway
continues if you would like to enter for
your chance to win all you have to do is
subscribe to my channel like this video
comment below with your thoughts and
your favorite superhero thank you all so
much for watching
woof woof
[Music]
you